[Music]
I think that one of the things that's
causing this funk that people are in is
that we're living our lives in these
very unfulfilled ways one of the reasons
why these people have this deep-seated
anger and resentment is there's a bunch
of people that are working all day long
doing something that is deeply
unsatisfying and an almost painful
they're stuck in traffic all day and
then they're stuck in a cubicle after
that they get in traffic on the way home
they get home after that they're
watching television and their [ __ ] we're
supposed to be out in the fields we're
supposed to be walking up hills we're
supposed to be looking for animals or
gathering vegetables we're supposed to
be doing all these things that our
bodies designed to do we're supposed to
be in nature and nature is like a
medicine like it literally is a medicine
to you you don't have to go hunting you
don't have to go fishing just go [ __ ]
hike man just go hike up to the top of a
mountain and look out you know there's a
reward that you get from that that is
intensely like soul filling we are
making a mistake with the way we live
our lives do a lot of people are trying
to get rich because they think that once
they get rich they'll be happy they
think that that's gonna give them this
thing that they've always been missing
and so they've been working hard bust
their ass and your life is just about
upping the ante and now I got to get a
yacht now I gotta buy an island now I'm
trying to find something to fill that
void because you've sort of set your
life up to chase these material goals
instead of to try to find out what
actually does make you happy
the pressure that to succeed the
hustle-and-bustle that people have is
not counterbalance we appreciate a
person who sleeps three hours a night
and [ __ ] is just hustling all day
long constantly hustling hustling
there's something to hard work and
hustle but man I think it should be
counterbalance look I'm as go-go-go as
anybody but I'm learning as I get older
you can't like be checking your phone
and checking your Twitter and checking
your email you gotta just somehow
another figure out a way to let go and a
lot of times we think the most important
thing is that financial success the most
important thing is this or that that's
all [ __ ] clearly your base has got
to be matters of the heart
understanding that loving each other
brothers and sisters and friends and
community has massive benefits and you
feel connected to each other and it is
the right way to be the best things in
life are connected to love and there's a
beauty in that that is magical
[Music]
you